one of my favorite players in the
national football league who i cannot
wait to see get back on the field he's a
pro bowler
he is the offensive rookie of the year
from back in his
first year day and um he's now an
entrepreneur
uh taking an ownership stake in a
company called x2 to tell us about all
of that
is saquon barkley back here on the rich
eisen show how are you saquon
i'm doing good rich how are you doing
i'm doing better for talking to you
i really am honestly um you know cause
uh you know uh for somebody who uh
ran all over my alma mater and relished
every single yard of it
uh and then was supposed to play for the
jets but wound up on the giants
um i i think you and i are still cool
you know
definitely definitely definitely cool i
would say i would say that for sure okay
is your dad over the fact that you don't
play for his beloved jets
is he over that yet or what um yeah he's
still he's still a jets fan
uh he kind of he has a jet tattoo
because he's kind of stuck with that
yes um but he's a big saquon barkley fan
so
uh he's rocking with me well that's good
to know that's good to know we
appreciate hearing all that uh let's get
right down to it uh saquon how
are you how are you feeling walk me
through i'm doing good i'm doing good
um taking it day by day um trying to get
one percent better
every single day um and enjoying time
obviously
camp is approaching soon uh so enjoying
time with my family and
and still trying to get the work and
that i can uh you know before things
ramp up
okay so are we uh
going to be on the pup list do you think
to start things off are you going to
just come back are we ready to roll what
do you got what do you got for me
um you know those are conversations i
actually haven't had yet um
so far um with the trainers and with the
coaches
uh the focus is you know take it one day
at a time and and kind of go with the
flow and listen to your body and listen
to your team
um and listen to the trainers okay uh
you're aware that joe judge comes from
the belichick world so he doesn't mind
you talking about injuries publicly go
for it
uh unburden yourself tell me everything
that's going on i think i think i know
better than that
i've been i've been i've been uh a
little bit now
okay i think i think i learned a thing
with two um
but yeah judge does is does is amazing
coach
does amazing job uh you know all the
coaches and and during this process you
know been very helpful
um not just only coach judge but from
from coach burns to coach gary to all
the coaches to all the trainers
and and strength coaches in new york and
nutrition guys in new york
have done an amazing job uh with me and
helping me prepare and
and uh you know really listening to me
listen to my body so
um i'm really excited obviously season's
starting up soon um but you know the
only thing i can do is to take about one
day at a time and
and keep that keep that approach okay so
uh that one day at a time winds up at
one point
to the first week of the season
do should is are we going to see you i
mean best you can tell
when you're listening to your body right
now does your body say week one
of the nfl season saquon barkley um no
you know my body tells me uh what's
what's next for the next what's ready
for the next day
um that's the only guy i could do i i
can't look too far
um i gotta take her one day at a time um
and keep that approach
um and you know like i said i'm very
fortunate enough to have an amazing team
and
amazing organization that you know that
is listening to me listening to my body
and
and and it's going to help me and do the
right thing by me
okay and but your your quads are still
as huge as as as ever right i still like
the size of my waist right
saquon are pretty pretty good
okay so you're ready you're right i'm
going to say that
i'm going to say that am i am i often
saying that that you're ready
no i can't nor agree or disagree
you are just locked in you're in
mid-season form
you are and you're like like i'm it's
like i'm talking to almost like end
season i'm talking to week 18 saquon
what do you think of the 17-week season
that's coming our 17-game season 18-week
season
what do you think of that do you like um
what do you think of this yeah i mean
actually that's the first time
i've been asked that questions to be
honest i guess it's the first time i'm
really even thinking about it um
[Music]
you know it don't bother me it is what
it is um
it's it's locked in it's it's happening
um you can't change it so you can't go
out there and complain about it you know
you know i think it's another
opportunity for us another week for us
to get better
um so keep with that mindset um
and take advantage of every opportunity
we get and without a week
you know try to do the things right uh
whenever that week comes
okay so saquon barkley here on the rich
eisen show
what's daniel jones's mindset best you
can tell because this is a very big year
for him
and you know we all know it's a
quarterback driven league he has
that ability that not many quarterbacks
have in the league which is
to run as well as throw be a dual threat
he can do that we saw
him damn near get uh arrest you know
pulled over for speeding when he ran
that that one time that he you know
obviously
couldn't stay up because he was running
so damn fast what
what is his what is he getting ready for
do you think for this season best you
can tell in his mind ready to roll for
the giants
um you know i really don't want to speak
on speak for daniel but
just knowing daniel um you know it is
what it is
he has amazing work ethic um i think
anyone
uh you know in the facility can see that
clear as day
um and he's a guy that's going to come
into work as a guy that's going to lead
you
and it's a guy that's going to compete
um so i think that's his mindset just
come in
uh try to get one percent better every
single day and lead this team okay
so um what do you think for the for this
season uh because i i
i you know you guys could be terrific i
mean you did have a season last year
without you uh that could have been
obviously
so much better with you and you you know
we're expecting you to return what are
your expectation levels for
the 2021 season saquon barkley what do
you have for me
yeah i mean we added a lot of talent on
both sides of the ball
um you know we have a great coaching
staff and you know we have
a lot of great young young talent a lot
of great guys on the team
um but for me it it's you know take care
today and take a couple weeks leading up
to camp um and then when we get into
camp
do whatever we can our best capability
um to prepare us for the season
and to have the best season that we can
possibly have
micah parsons is might be filling a hole
there for the dallas cowboys looks like
you're going to be
facing an italian lion in the whole
twice a year now yeah
um yeah i'm excited i'm excited for him
um you know real close friends with
micah
um know him personally well he's amazing
talent i
obviously hate to see him uh hate that
i'm have to see him two times a year
right um but you know dallas did an
amazing job with that pig and
i think for for years to come uh there's
gonna be lots of positive things said
about
michael parsons and and what he's able
to do and his talent
football field miles sanders is in
philadelphia the nfc east is kind of
like you know
penn state of football it seems like
right now to me yeah miles miles is
you know i don't get it miles don't get
enough credit um
in my opinion he's a tremendous back
obviously when you just study the game
you watch the game especially being up
for a year you get to watch it a little
bit more um not just only focusing on
yourself with this film right um but
like i said
he's amazing um you know the things he's
able to do and he has he can do it all
he can run in between tackles outside of
tackles
um and this year i think he's shown at
that home on speed um so
i i feel like people should start
talking more about milestones and
um if not even if they're not you're
going to continue to just continue to
work and
uh continue to make big plays for a team
when you can and then your teammate
uh from penn state carl nasib had a
remarkable announcement
um a couple of weeks ago that one day
hopefully
won't have to be made as an announcement
uh have you contacted him
since uh his announcement in las vegas
uh and becoming yeah um i damn i said
congrats um and he was able to get back
to me um but you know i'm just happy for
him
um you know he found his piece uh he he
he's doing what he loved and he was able
to announce
a way you love and you know like you
said one day hopefully one day
it's not a thing where it feels that it
needs to be announced
um it's kind of just expected it's kind
of something that's the norm in the nfl
and
i think him and obviously with michael
sam and years before and you know other
athletes and
other sports uh being pioneers for for
people that
um if that's the way that they feel um
they're able to come out and be able to
just
have no words behind it and just be able
to play the sport they love and live the
life that they want to live and quite an
announcement during pride month in june
and there are people who are saying that
carl nasa by coming out and saying i
am a gay man um it could have saved
lives
people's lives potentially saquon it is
pretty neat
when you think about it is that it
definitely is definitely me and
you know for me i didn't even think
about it that way um and
yeah what he did was very special and
like i said i'm happy for him and you
know
uh proud of him and you know that he was
able to find his piece and come out
with his piece and uh continue to do the
thing that he loves uh also too and
that's play football
sequon barkley pro bowl running back new
york giant running back and
now entrepreneur here on the rich eisen
show what is
x2 what is this all about and why are
you a part owner
of x2 squam barkley well x2
you know they got it all they got powder
they got shots they got energy drinks
and the reason why um you know i i was
i'm able to build a partner with them
and love and i'm able to be a partner
with them
um one it gotta be authentic um you know
me and
that's something that that's big that's
big with me and i feel like where the
world is going to
but with that white space and why i
think x2 can really dominate
uh is because the world's becoming more
healthier um and there's a healthier way
um for you to maintain energy uh help
with your recovery
uh help you get stronger help you get
better as an athlete
um and for me that's something that's
really important for me uh with
obviously coming off the injury and
looking at my career and just wanting to
you know sustain longevity and be able
to play as long as i possibly can
you look for ways like this and you look
for um trains like this and x2
um me personally my favorite thing is is
the energy drink
i'm a big fan of food punch but like i
said
they have they're just so versatile with
everything that they're doing
um and also the biggest thing for being
a professional athlete
um you know why i stand by is nsf
certified
um and and that means it's not tainted
with nothing you don't gotta worry about
nothing
uh you can go get your work in and be
able to use the strength and not worry
about anything that is coming back or
haunting you
later on down the line so uh you are
uh in the ownership stake and so is
kawhi
leonard is that a true story as well the
club yeah kawhi leonard
uh levante david um you know there's
others that that's also involved too
um and to be able to you know align
yourself with the likes of those guys
who are very special players and who've
done a lot of great things
on or off the field in the court um
that's also a
important thing for me too to be able to
align myself uh with those players and
just know
that you know this thing's gonna be
special and um this thing's gonna really
help change the world
any conversations with kawhi did you do
have you met him have you talked with
him or just the mere fact that
um i've met kawhi years before um
nickelodeon
award showcase to be honest um but no
uh you know after announcement have not
been able to
to get in contact with kawhi but i'm
pretty sure something's coming up soon
we're gonna be in contact with what
we're talking about are you saying you
were slimed together is that what you
were saying did you not i don't i didn't
get swam
we didn't get swam but um i i would love
to be slimed one day so
i think that's cool and i remember
growing up as a kid and seeing that
happening
um so hopefully one day that i can
accomplish that i think we can make that
happen
um did i also see is it is it true that
an investor in x2 along with saquon
barkley
you and kawhi leonard is adam schefter
did chef do you put in his hard-earned
uh american dollars into this venture as
well saquon is that true yeah
yeah yeah i believe so yeah he did well
that's that's
that's where my competitive juices get
going i mean you know that's
you know um if you're accepting money
from michigan man i mean
how how did i wind up on the x2.0
mindless i'm the one who runs a 40 i'm
the one who actually
gets out there and shows off my actual
physical skill set
sequan i think uh kind of a natural
thing i think i know some some people
really well
uh where we can to help you get on the
next round
and also i think you need some some of
the the power shot some of the shots
okay before you take that 40 next year
to get you ready well how much sooner
how how far in advance will i have to
start something like that because i
don't know
you know i don't know if i really have
the the year-round mindset i mean i'm a
michigan man i forgot the tb-12 system
thing in me
maybe i should i mean you know it's it's
simple you can go to subway
gnc okay amazon there you go there's a
lot of places where you can get it
um i know that 40 is big for you it is i
mean i think this could help you break
your record so far
all right saquon i'm gonna take that to
the bank and literally i might have to
go to the bank to be part of this thing
shafter makes a lot of money um all
right so uh before i let you go
saquon barkley i have the first overall
selection in my fantasy draft
i choose you we're good everything good
i take you what do you think should i
take you
my fantasy draft oh i i i mean
to be completely honest yes i would say
one that's up to you but
um if i was a betting man i mean i was
told the best thing is better yourself
so
i would say why not okay you know i'm
keep
i'm just trying to chop wood to find out
from you if you're out there week one
i'm just all i'm trying to do i'm just
chopping wood on that front so i'm
taking you first overall in my draft and
i'm gonna sit back and enjoy it
immensely
is what you're saying yes yes i believe
so i know so
you know so i love it yeah hey saquon
thanks
thanks uh for everything i always
appreciate when you come on my show and
we
we chop it up and congrats on on
entering
uh you know ownership stake of something
that you love and something that
uh you can actually be about with x2
congratulations on that
thank you boss i appreciate that let's
do this again soon let's do this again
soon
thanks for the call saquon take care you
bet that's saquon barkley pro bowl
running back
number 26 in your program number one in
my fantasy draft
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here